you think you can fix me
gene you are not broken
[Music]
the mind is a fragile thing takes only
the slightest tap
to tip it in the wrong direction
charles what did you do
i had to keep her stable i protected her
from the truth
there's another word for that
[Music]
i came looking for answers
[Applause]
you feel like you don't belong here you
don't
[Music]
they can't begin to comprehend what you
are she's changing and
what you didn't come here looking for
answers
you came here looking for permission
[Music]
she's all rage
pain that's all coming out at once
gene lost control was she still our
friend this is your fault
the charles is on the brink i'm sorry i
didn't stop it sooner
you're always sorry charles and there's
always a speech
and nobody cares there's still
hope don't do this
[Applause]
they're right to fear me
i've seen evil
[Applause]
and i'm looking at it now
hey everybody we finally got the
official dark phoenix trailer it's time
to break it down you probably recognized
a whole bunch of stuff there from the
comics or from x-men the animated series
but i'll try to explain what's going on
especially with the main villain
being played by jessica chastain there's
a new round of that spider-man ps4
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be subscriber and leave a comment on the
video what it seems like based on the
footage is as they're doing the dark
phoenix saga from the comics
minus some of the shia empire space
based story
so i don't think that jessica chastain
is playing lilandra like i initially
suspected when they first cast her
the shiar empire part of the story was
such a big part of all the previous
retellings of the comic book story so it
was just kind of taken on faith that
they would incorporate that
but this seems a little more grounded
more about jean
versus the x-men her hurting all of her
friends which is a big part of that
comic book story
so you start out with a flashback to her
initially coming to the x-men they said
you could help me
and it sounds like based on his
conversation with mystique
professor x messed with jean's mind so
that she wouldn't remember
accidentally killing her family when her
powers manifested
the whole thing with jean grey is that
even without the phoenix force she's an
omega level mutant so she was powerful
before she was ever infused with that
you see later in the trailer they go
into outer space that's when she's hit
with the phoenix force they make it very
fantastic for type of cosmic radiation
description like she's hit with a
mysterious force of energy while they're
in outer space
that's the phoenix force jumping into
her body you see her infused with it but
you kind of got a taste for that during
x-men apocalypse so i don't know how
they're going to explain
them going into outer space and relative
continuity because you see them wearing
these new x-men uniforms from the comics
and the timeline for x-men apocalypse
wouldn't totally make sense if they do
this
she turned into the phoenix then they
went into outer space so we'll just have
to wait for more footage to explain the
timeline
but the way they pose this here is like
you see beast examining her
and then later you see him with magneto
and the other people from genocide
that's right they're doing the island of
genocia
it looks kind of like a hippie commune
right now like he's just created it
and it's meant to take the place of the
hellfire club
in the comics so i'll explain that in a
second but you see
beast with her here he probably
sympathizes with her then sort of jumps
sides when he finds out what professor x
is planning on doing to subdue her
later in the timeline when she gets
really crazy so they're doing a little
bit of x-men
schism in addition to jean grey going
full phoenix and hurting some of her
friends
i love the look on magneto's face when
she walks up he's
like what the hell what are you doing
here he probably realizes how powerful
she is
then later in the trailer when she
starts to go super dark
you see her start destroying those
military helicopters
probably because she just wanted to
protect everyone here and just sort of
gave in to the darkness within her
like earlier in the trailer professor x
is talking about how a balanced mind can
swing
one way or the other just depending on
triggers so we'll see what the actual
thing that triggers her is but it might
just be the military coming to genocia
gunning people down
the whole thing with jessica chastain's
character is that a lot of people
think that she might be a female
gender-bent
mr sinister as in miss sinister he's
done that in the past in the comics and
she's the sort of stand-in for the
hellfire club
the whole thing in the comics is that
emma frost in the hellfire club wanted
to co-opt
jean grey and turn her evil so
eventually they were able to mess with
her mind
for a little while at least jean grey
became the black queen of the hellfire
club
so this could be that version but i
don't know that the hellfire club itself
is an actual part of the movie so this
could just be say
mrs sinister or a different version of
emma frost
just trying to twist jean grey evil for
her own purposes
her to tell if this is before or after
jean grey goes to jenosha because she's
wearing the same jacket
but this might be when she does
something really messed up the x-men try
to stop her
and she thinks that there's nothing to
be done about it so she just wants to go
off into the wilderness and hang out on
this island where she doesn't think that
she can hurt anybody
then you have that slow montage of her
just completely losing her [ __ ]
in the x-men slowly breaking apart
because of what's going on
like you can understand that professor x
does something to mess with her mind to
prevent her from going
full phoenix so not all the x-men are on
board for that like beast here seems
like he's at odds which is probably
why he's standing with magneto later in
the trailer this shot of him inside
cerebro getting the full psychic blast
of the phoenix force is
him probably trying to figure out what
happened to gene
on the spacecraft like when she was hit
with that special radiation
they're examining her inside the medical
bay this is him probably trying to do
the instant replay inside her mind so he
looks inside her
and all he sees is just fire reaching
out at him
obviously they're playing that cover of
the doors this is the end and then you
see them standing over that grave
one of the other x-men probably gets
killed accidentally by something that
jean grey does
and that's what causes her to want to
leave to go to genocia
totally digging all these shots of
magneto if you haven't seen it there
were some behind the scenes pictures of
him
playing chess with professor x it's just
a reference to them beginning
the chess game that they played during
the patrick stewart ian mckellen x-men
movies
this shot of her is probably about as
close as we get to her with full
phoenix force but obviously it's going
to look a little crazier because you
look at these mock-up shots that they
released earlier this year
this is what she'll look like when the
phoenix has fully taken over her mind
so it'll be interesting to see how they
conclude this because the comic book
version was jean grey realizing that the
only way to save everyone
was to kill herself so because if you
guys didn't know this is like the swan
song for fox x-men movies before they go
back to marvel
so i don't know how they're gonna try
and bookend all the fox x-men films or
if this is going to be more
self-contained
but the fact that they use that door
song this is the end is important for
the phoenix
storyline but also in a really meta way
for the x-men characters
at fox in the movies like this is the
end for fox's x-men movies
well let me know in the comments what do
you guys think of this obviously it
looks way more grounded than the comic
book version or even from the 90s
animated series
they did dark phoenix saga in five
episodes so i don't know where that's
streaming but you can actually probably
go find that right now
so the movie's coming out at the
beginning of february meaning that we'll
probably get a whole bunch more footage
before the end of the year and we can
try to figure out a little bit more
about what's going on with their
timeline and who jessica chastain is
playing exactly
the real sea bass congratulations you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your details
click here to learn all about brand new
iron man armor during avengers 4
and click here to learn all about black
costume during spider-man far from home
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight